andreas doer ditched his career in
banking to launch a new startup
he organizes dragon boat races nobody's
this world work is so loaded there's
this pressure that you have to work I
feel that way I freed myself because
it's my life stuff when you lose policy
minuses of the still maybe it was my
calling this perspective lets you see a
bit more it gives me power and I want
the things I'm doing to evolve in that
sense I'm closer to a calling than if
you have some abstract little job you're
doing for somebody else
Catherina blends old job was advertising
consultant for an IT firm now she runs
her own firm super craft designing
handicraft kits for people to make their
own bags customized clothes and
accessories the mental strain used to be
really high at the same time I was
completely under challenged at Deloitte
evil there had burnouts because of the
stress but in human terms you're below
your potential the jobs are too small
for what we're actually capable of only
flair something most of the demand for
her do-it-yourself kits comes from women
he get to rediscover old-fashioned
handicrafts ones and her business
partner bring out a new idea every two
months each time a new one comes out
several thousand orders flood into their
online store I had a very good job and
was very comfortable I struggled when I
first became self-employed but now I'm
earning more money plus nobody tells her
where and when to work and she has no
problem balancing her job with her
private life jobs jobs tend to comprise
what other people want and expect from
year
now my work is what I want and expect
from myself it's a huge difference
realizing that can change your whole
life
the higher your qualifications the lower
the job satisfaction tends to be water
globe it's runs workshops explaining how
to succeed in taking that step you
suffer if you end up with something
random because you couldn't find
anything better job like that takes a
lot out but gives you nothing in return
ok what you get is money to pay the rent
but there are a lot of people who were
saying that's not enough they want to do
something they can connect with like
andreas doer he's turned a passion into
his profession he also made his move
after consulting an expert now he
organizes over 80 sporting events a year
for up to 1,000 people companies booked
things like dragon boat races to
motivate employees with a wife and
children to support he had to seriously
weigh the risk involved skip the movie
Duff has and everyone's they should have
had you always get times when you wonder
if you've reached your limit so you need
to be alert and show humility don't take
it too seriously when things are going
well and the same thing if you're down
and out you never know maybe something
good will come out of Ajit we have ice
for fourth quarters for now Andreas
certainly has great job satisfaction
whether there are choppy waters on the
horizon or not
you